are a musician or vocalist that's ready
to take center stage now is your chance
here to tell us about open mic night at
the Virgin hotel is host and very
talented musician Sean iverman welcome
oh you make me feel like the pretty girl
on the school bus well you are so you're
you're hosting this open mic night at
the Virgin hotel and you're looking for
the next big star tell us a little bit
about it
um I didn't think it was going to work
ironically enough I played the opening
stuff for the Virgin it's great to see
it transition from the Hard Rock the
good old days I've been around forever
yeah and I I wasn't really looking to
become sort of the Ryan Seacrest of
hosting a situation like this and then
Boz the owner and he and the GM and all
these folks were like hey this went
really well for the grand opening what
would happen if we turned this room one
night in a week into an open mic like a
real open mic and you're talking about
the Shag room right that is such a great
part of the Virgin hotel but it is so
not like an open mic Vibe if you think
of open mics it's kind of a coffee shop
in Portland there's an acoustic guitar
scattered in the corner and you know you
go over there and you sign up and this
is full backline we we have a sound
engineer there's drones keyboards
people win staycations at the hotel and
concert tickets we do a sort of a season
long thing 12 weeks every Wednesday
There's a new best performance every
single week and there they get little
prizes or perks and then at the end of
the 12 weeks we've got to have you come
and judge oh yeah finale is we have a
finale and the finale creates uh
basically the talent pool for their
booking so you're really kind of
auditioning for a real show for real
booking this this next Thursday is the
first performance of the last season
winner oh wow so for Open Mic people to
be able to like transition and step up
to the next level to go from sort of the
open mic vibe to getting a paid
residency gig like a real booking what
do you dream of is pretty Next Level so
if you are if someone's sitting here
watching right now thinking well I'm a
pretty good singer I'd like to give it a
shot how do they do it so it's kind of
funny there's a this is true there's a
mannequin out front that we call shag
room Steve and we put a t-shirt on the
mannequin and it has a QR code and you
just walk up and scan the QR code you're
kidding me it automatically populates
you into the queue for the sign up sheet
and we also write it on a big whiteboard
but that's all you gotta do is show up
the first chat room Steve
uh it's first come first serve it's
still open Mike it's still you know we
can only go one person at a time so we
get people showing up at like 7 15 for
an 8 o'clock start time every Wednesday
okay I'm gonna hang out in that front
bar get a drink you know you want to
warm up with some liquid courage yeah
why not and then we open the doors at
eight and it's gangbusters from eight
o'clock on we haven't it's been a year
since we've been doing this Open Mic
thing every Wednesday for a year at the
Shag at the Virgin and we haven't had a
slow night we haven't we have 20 to 25
people every Wednesday that are just
signing up the list is usually about 22
to 25 people what about what do they do
for music do you do they bring their own
music do you have a band what do you are
challenged I am challenged with that uh
question because I wanted to stay
organic and so it's very open it's an
open Open Mic so we've had
bagpipe players come in I'm not joking
we've had country rock hip-hop every
genre old young we had two women that
didn't know each other come in with
flutes oh wow separate and had a flute
battle it's hard to say it's amazing
crazy so because of that we also have
the opportunity for somebody that has
tracks or has something on their phone
to plug in again we have a sound
engineer Guitar Center has supplied some
of the backline equipment it's a Next
Level Open Mic I kind of I'm like I
think we're going to try and make this
the coolest open mic in the country it
sounds amazing that's why I'm wearing my
red virgin
well you're so talented I hope maybe you
perform for us at one of these Open Mic
nights every once in a while yeah and
well I do have to wrap a bow on that
there's a room full of musicians if you
wanted to come in and just sing and
don't have tracks there's literally a
room full of people that'll you know we
can bring some bagels from the earlier
piece and some of the
it's a lot of fun it's a variety show
it's something different pretty much
every 10 minutes Sean thank you so much
for telling us about us open Bike Night
at the chat room inside the Virgin it
happens every Wednesday